hi guys I'm back again and it's time to
support this coasting so might as well
get started a
it's gonna make
alright guys the first ghost of this
bike is now officially finished and all
I still need to do is path work and some
more attractions and all that kind of
stuff but for now this is it this is the
layout these are the supports and it's
pretty much finished and I thought it
would be cool to record a POV of this
the only problem is wait this is pretty
cool
the only problem is that this is pro
probably getting to like a lot but we'll
see please do that a little faster
good oh really
we're going to do that well this camera
then we yay and we're flying and there's
blue lines on the ground this element
right it's pretty cool I still need to
change the camera though right oh there
that's better right it's pretty smooth
now I don't really like the camera
positions as much as I like the car spot
I guess I'll have to do with this it's
not all that bad I mean it still looks
pretty cool that was a lack spike it
basically lags as soon as the camera is
facing the buildings because it has to
render all these little details and
stuff and it doesn't appear to really
like to do that so yeah that's the only
problem I've got here so stay away from
all those buildings and you're fine
basically so yeah that's it guys see you
guys next episode in which I'll probably
try to do some paths and I know how it I
don't know how I'm going to do it with
the leg because while building these
supports you probably noticed it I
didn't show all of the footage because
sometimes my game just liked so much I
got one frame per second I couldn't even
built the freakin sports so I hope that
next time the game is going to cooperate
a little bit better so I can actually
record something at juicing
so until then
you